this is this is prime territory and
highly spiritually involved area you
know found in my own church called
Church of the earth for generations in
California my aunt was the first baby
girl born in the city of Venice in 1902
in a bikini named or Venice we had the
run of the place because my uncle was a
policeman and my family had lived there
all those years and had the dairy farm
there and help build the piers we fish
off the pier and who was fun and that's
when they still had the red cars you
know I mean when they had they had a
complete transit system built into this
area and then they tore it all out you
know you can bleed on and they were fun
to ride to
you